so we're you're here you wanted to
promote some things and let's talk about
those things our friendship that's pure
and we did that already
we did it but you produced and directed
a documentary yes which you already
talked about on this podcast I have I
talked about this podcast already
amazing Jonathan but the amazing job
okay would you say about what I say
about it you just read his text message
on air oh yeah and then you and then
what did you say afterwards that's what
I'm interested in I do think I don't
think they're nothing negative you were
very smug about the fact that your
response you gave him a one-word
response thank you thank you for what
says I accurate yeah that's very
accurate when I when I was texting about
this stuff he's like I said hey I texted
you a few times I just I'm trying to get
the calendar like the schedule of all my
friends podcast together and then and
then you said this is what you said to
me you go you go yeah I didn't get back
to you
I go why and you said you'll see you'll
see and you were like doing a power trip
on me you were teaching you said you
were teaching me a lesson I think what
you're saying I'm teaching the lesson
okay it's unbearable
so let's go Friday the 13th on that okay
I want to say this what I was just
asking hey I don't know what day and
time cuz everybody's schedule
ding-a-ling 50 is [ __ ] childhood
[ __ ] names now okay King dong okay
it's enough yes scallop my body yeah and
you I used to say that about you then
you started saying about yourself so
that is for my writing credit for that
yeah you claimed writing card for like a
one-line a one-line are you up alright
so when I go up on stage I'll go Steve
Byrne wrote that okay what do you want
to say what it's what do you want to say
I forgot because I'm so emotional
because I know you were teaching me a
lesson I wasn't teaching one lesson
here's the thing though I'm like what
communication you what what does Chris
D'Elia say about me right
yeah what does anyone say about my
agents my agents after splitting up
together and that cancelled two weeks
ago have called me 30 times not one time
have I called them back because I don't
want to hear how do you do that because
I don't want to hear hey pal you know
we'll get you another thing you'll be
back on the horn I don't want to hear
your an that garbage right I know what
it is it's political right
I'm not small talking right so it's like
you know um I think that has a lot to do
with that you know and I would never of
course you would be on this [ __ ]
podcast we just had scheduling problems
and that's why I said that [ __ ] you
know he was he was texting about
scheduling look at you can't even you're
such a weasel scheduling problems okay
you had no schedule the problem was you
didn't know when I was scheduled that's
right correct yeah so I was trying to
figure out with everybody with Kalin
with the segura with everybody or
Santino it's like okay great great
podcast group by the way yeah and I
didn't want to miss out on this
incredibly would never miss out because
can I say this is we did an extra one
for you today okay we did my [ __ ] two
hours somebody else right and I did an
extra with you because I want to get it
in the [ __ ] bag right so I don't have
to wait a month when we got this opening
yes
no I'm being real thank you we're gonna
do this and this is gonna be we're gonna
put mark this whenever you want it out
we'll get this out okay okay and we're
gonna promote the [ __ ] out of Johnny
Johnny or whatever you [ __ ]
documentary filmed whoever with the
magic right we're gonna [ __ ] a promotes
Evelyn sons to coming out on time yeah
okay we're gonna promote all the stuff
that you do are your shells yeah your
big live shows that you do okay so are
you happy you [ __ ] dingbat no check
me check me out check me out
all right right oh it's buried again
bury it again
Wow the casket with the hatchet you you
insult me then you bury the head
yeah you dingbat in any way yeah yeah
yeah you love me or what I love you do
you love me say it out loud I want to
hear it I'm so glad this is all
happening why cuz I feel like I can
never explain how he treats me as a
human being and then now it's all I am
just as confused as you as his partner
yeah and I think that sometimes you
can't tackle Bobby with reason or
rationale you just sort of have to play
his game a little bit and play into the
psychosis to get a little bit bad but
here's the good news you're a 10 and you
can leave him at any time I don't wanna
he has got baited in so hard oh yeah
your Korean five and you're an L a three
yeah it's so funny that you say that
because here they had other sexy and
some comic good because I'm gonna say
this to you my friend all right you can
pretend you're white all you want but
you've got Korean inside you I met your
mom when do I pretend I'm one all right
I met your mom
yeah she's full-blown 100% full-blown
yeah like she has AIDS okay
she has full-blown Korean yes she's a
Fed right but yeah and she's dying from
it she needs to be a guest of medicine
okay but your mom is Korean yes he has
the accent yeah she's Korean I know yes
she smells like kimchi jjigae yeah right
you know what kimchi jjigae is right if
you stuck in your belly button [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
this is so you know why because when I
did your podcast this never happened
what we're doing now I was polite to you
nope this is what I love this is a magic
he likes a little drama is what it comes
down to it yeah and he likes to confuse
you so much into submission like he
wants to just sort of
this is his style where he'll go in and
hurt you but retract go in retract that
you're so confused about how you feel
that you end up saying sorry let's get
coffee after this I agree yeah I'm so
glad it's all coming out but you know
what
this is gonna make me a snowflake it
doesn't make me the thing about Gilbert
be on my side for ya Gilbert doesn't it
make me special no you're like hail that
snowflake is song it's alright right
watch it come on hail hit you in the
head
curious and then it melts something to
defend me please
you're unique that's it that's all you
got
cuz I'm also confused I also don't know
if you like me or not or let's just
throw this out there and let's get this
out of the way okay you know you're
right everyone's right I have issues and
I don't you don't think when I'm saying
certain things I'm going why are you
saying that you mean don't call that fat
guy a fat guy oh whatever right I have
those things on my head don't poke his
belly you don't know um I poke fat guys
in the belly before huh yeah I've called
okay yeah go ahead with with what you're
dispelling right now right you're you're
unpacking emotionally for us right now
and we're acknowledging some things do
you understand now why I think can in
the past has felt the way he has well I
felt in the past the way I have but I
think I have a good rapport and then
there are things that you put in your
head per what you believe about other
people and I just don't think it's okay
you're right you're right and that's I'm
not that when you said that earlier it
wasn't something that I was confused
about if I'm 100% [ __ ] that I do right I
know this because you know I've been in
recovery I've done steps I know you know
that I imagine 90% of my problems even
probably even more yeah but I also do
know when things are a little awry
and and I'm being people putting shade
on me right right right yeah
I'm not dumb in that way right right and
I and I and I want to say this to you is
is that um yeah I do imagine a lot of
stuff but some of it and even though I
didn't you know mean push from my point
of view during what your your side of
the story right I still believe in some
of my side do you understand today I do
know that about me that I did I am a
weird guy I um you know I I create
problems in my head but a lot of these
things not even a lot that everybody's
got their own soils
yeah I mean I definitely I think I think
you know you look you just try to do
your best representation of yourself I
think all the time and I think that
what's even more difficult is just this
environment this industry it is
difficult to I think at times stay
positive and and walk towards the light
you know cuz we will all had our hiccups
we've all had our setbacks and stuff but
I think you just try to do your best
friend I think that with him his heart
doesn't match his hands his heart
doesn't match his mouth I know that deep
down he is one of the most loving most
generous most kind-hearted people I've
ever met he does match his mouth though
his stomach matches his mouth yeah
that's right his every everything else
is just he's very reckless reckless is a
good word it's a beautiful word and yet
the word of that the podcast reckless I
agree though I agree